SUBHASISH CHAKRABORTY: A very
warm welcome to everyone.
I'm Subhasish, product manager
for Google Cloud Storage
or GCS, and I have with me
Chester, tech lead for GCS,
as well.
And in this session,
we're going to learn
about some important security
capabilities and best practices
to keep your data safe and
secure at scale on GCS.
So, agenda.
First we're going to
look at GCS as a product
and its various capabilities.
Then we're going to go through
some highly differentiated
security fundamentals
that GCS has to offer.
And then Chester is
going to take you
through some highlighted
security features
and some security best practices
to secure your data at scale.
And then we're going to do the
demo, which will put together
these various security
capabilities and best
practices.
Introduction-- what is
GCS and why it is awesome.
So GCS, or Google Cloud
Storage, is GCP's object
or block storage product.
It's a very simple product
to use, from the customer
perspective, because
of various reasons,
but two fundamental reasons.
One is that GCS offers
a consistent API
across all different
storage classes.
And the second is GCS offers
uniform online latency
characteristics across all
different storage classes.
So, whether you are interacting
with the hottest storage
class or the coldest
storage class,
your core doesn't need to
change because it pays the same.
And your handling
in the code doesn't
need to change because across
all these different storage
classes you have the same
online latency characteristics.
GCS is highly
reliable, GCS offers
various geo-redundancy
options, ranging from a region,
to a country, to a continent,
based on what your use case is.
And GCS is highly
cost effective.
You can leverage object
lifecycle management
to spread your cost across
all different storage
classes of GCS.
Now, last but not the least, and
the focus of the session, GCS
is highly secure and
is inbuilt with a bunch
of fundamental
security capabilities
that you get straight away
off the box when you use GCS.
So in terms of key
features, I have already
mentioned about the
unified experience
through the APIs and the
latency characteristics.
So GCS offers strongly
consistent listing worldwide
and what we see
is, other than GCS,
when other public cloud
storages are being used,
customers usually use
a key value database
to drive this consistency
because they do not
get it off the box with other
public cloud storage offerings.
But that is an additional
unit of cost and management
which you do not
have to do with GCS.
I've already mentioned
geo-redundancy.
The other great aspect
of using GCS is you
do not need to worry
about scale at all.
We have single customers in GCS
who scale to exabytes of data.
Now, in terms of
the use cases, we
see a standard
storage class being
used in two different
classes of use cases.
We see dual regional and
regional standard location
types being used for highly
compute intensive use cases,
for example, for high
performance computing,
or for analytics, or
for machine learning.
What we also see is
customers leverage
GCS's multi-regional
storage locations.
[? CDM-like ?] characteristics
because of its intelligent edge
caching and routing capabilities
for content distribution use
cases.
And nearline line great if
what you are looking to do
is backup.
Coldline is great if what you
are looking to do is archive.
And the archive
storage class itself
is great if what
you are trying to do
is to do long term archival
for regulatory or compliance
purposes.
So what we see is archive
storage class is a great tape
replacement, but once you have
your data in archive storage
class, your data is still
alive, it's in the serving tier.
And that brings me to the fact
that once you have your data
in GCS you have this great
advantage that the entire data
platform that is Google
is now open to you.
So once you have
your data in GCS
whatever it is that you
want to do with your data,
whether you want to run
AI or machine learning
or you want to do
analytics, whatever
it is that you want to do you
can do once you have landed
your data in GCS.
Now security is not an
afterthought for us in GCS.
We have built GCS with security
as a fundamental primitive,
and this starts with
Google's private network.
So Google possibly has
the world's largest
private network.
So we have thousands
of edge node locations,
we have hundreds of
POP node locations.
So wherever you are
producing your data
or consuming your data from,
you are never too far away
from one of Google's
edge or POP locations.
And how that helps
you a lot is, say
if you are in a
particular location
and you are writing your data
to a Google Cloud Storage
packet in a different region.
With GCS, your
data packets enter
Google's closest
[? call, ?] and then
it traverses Google's
private network
all the way up to the region.
Now, if you compare it
with another public cloud
vendor, what would
happen is your data
packets would pass through
the public internet
up to the region where
your data is stored.
You have much higher
exposure that way.
When you use GCS
your data packets
are flowing through
Google's private network
for most of its lifetime.
So your exposure to public
internet is as low as possible.
Encryption is another very
important aspect of security
and with GCS all your
data is always encrypted.
So whether it is
your data in-flight,
or whether it is your data at
rest, all of your data in GCS
is always encrypted.
And we offer you entire
range in terms of choice
for managing your
encryption keys.
So whether you want to use
customer supplied encryption
keys, or do you want to use
customer managed encryption
keys, or hardware
security module,
or you just want to use Google's
default automatic encryption,
you have all your
choices when you use GCS.
And then the last part
that I would emphasize
on GCS's fundamental--
security fundamentals
is, even if you use the
more sophisticated security
capability with GCS, for
example, if you use KMS keys,
or if you want to put your GCS
buckets behind the VPC security
firewall, you do not have
to pay any penalty in terms
of your performance or your SLS.
We have built all the
security capabilities with GCS
from ground up so that your
experience of using them
is the same as if you
are using GCS, even
without these features.
In terms of the
performance and the SLS,
there is absolutely no
penalty that you need to pay.
With that, I'm going
to hand it over
to Chester, who's going to
take you through some security
features and some best
practices and then
we're going to
end with the demo.
Take it over, Chester.
CHESTER CUN: Thanks, Sub.
The features I'll
be going over today
are uniform bucket-level access,
IAM conditions, service account
HMAC keys, and V4 signatures.
Uniform bucket-level
access went GA last year,
and this is a
bucket-level setting
that lets you simplify access
control across all objects
within a bucket.
When enabled permissions are
managed using the bucket's IAM
policy, disabling the use
of individual object ACLs.
Since all objects now share
the same configuration,
it's much easier to tell
if any objects are publicly
exposed to the internet.
By inspecting your
bucket policy,
you can quickly determine who
can or cannot access your data.
Uniform bucket-level
access also helps
you leverage a
security feature called
domain restricted
sharing, which enforces
that all members
of an IAM policy
must be within a
specified domain.
IAM conditions brings
attribute-based access control
to GCS, by extending
IAMs policy language
with conditional bindings.
This recently GA
feature allows you
to grant access based on a
resource name or a request
timestamp.
A simple example that
combines both attributes is
if you tried to grant future
access to all objects whose
names started with 2020 slash.
I've also included
a cell expression
at the bottom of the
slide that you could use
to implement such a condition.
Some of you may already be
familiar with user account HMAC
keys, but I'd like to introduce
you to service account HMAC
keys, which are now GA.
Service account HMAC keys are
similar to user account in that
they're also a type
of credential that
can be used to
create signatures,
which you can include
in your requests to GCS.
These signatures
show that the request
is authorized by the
entity that owns the HMAC
key, delegating that entity's
access to the request.
You manage service
account HMAC keys
by calling our APIs to generate
HMAC credentials, which consist
of an access key and a secret.
So if you're already
using user account HMAC,
there's no need to
change your code.
You can simply update
the access key and secret
that your code is using.
With service account
HMAC you'll also
get better key
lifecycle management.
From the cloud console
UI, you can quickly
create, rotate, disable,
and delete your HMAC keys.
And lastly, service
account HMAC is
interoperable with other public
clouds, which will enable
your app for multi cloud.
For customers who work with
multiple public clouds,
GCS has also gone GA with
our V4 signature support.
V4 enables you to access
multiple object stores
with the same
client code and it's
available for both RSA and
service account HMAC keys.
Now, I'd like to show you
how these features can help
you secure your data at scale.
To start, I'll go over
fundamentals like org policies
and the differences between
Cloud IAM and GCS ACLs.
I'll also explain how uniform
bucket-level access simplifies
access control at scale.
And then I'll conclude
with some best practices
for using HMAC keys with GCS.
Within GCP, all
resources conform
to a resource hierarchy.
GCS is no different,
your buckets hold objects
and they're associated
with projects,
and projects can be
nested inside folders
and are tied to organizations.
Org policies are
settings that you
can figure at the org,
folder, or project level,
to enforce a service
specific behavior.
So remember that all resources
inherit from org policies set
higher in the hierarchy,
so if you set an org
policy at the org level,
it would cover all GCS
buckets in its tree.
And lastly, org
policies themselves
are not retroactive
because they take effect
after they're enforced.
So hypothetically, if there
was an org policy that
prevented buckets from being
created in a specific region,
enabling it now wouldn't
impact any buckets
that were created before
that org policy was enforced.
The two org policies that we
recommend enabling with GCC
are domain restricted
sharing and
uniform bucket-level access.
The first one prevents
users from adding members
outside your organization
to IAM policies controlling
access to your GCS resources.
So if you tried to make the
contents of the bucket public
to the internet by adding all
users member to the bucket
policy, this org
policy, when enabled,
would block that operation.
And I'll cover this in the demo.
The second org policy enforces
the use of uniform bucket level
access, so after
you enable this,
all newly created
buckets are required
to manage their access uniformly
through the bucket policy.
And this is also
covered in the demo.
The easiest way
to set org policy
is through the Cloud Console UI.
For certain org policies, like
domain restricted sharing,
you will need to know
your organization's domain
ID, as well.
And if you don't have
it, totally fine.
You can always use
G Cloud to find it.
I'd like to go over a brief
history of GCS access control.
In the beginning, GCS
only supported ACLs,
and then Cloud IAM came along,
and GCS integrated with IAM
at the bucket level.
So today, when you
configure access to GCS,
you should be aware
that there are actually
two systems at play here.
There's Cloud IAM
and there's GCS ACLs.
Access can be granted
from either system,
but Cloud IAM behaves like
work policies in that they also
follow the resource hierarchy.
So any object permissions, when
granted at the bucket level,
they automatically apply to all
objects underneath that bucket.
GCS ACLs on the other
hand, they do not
follow research hierarchy.
They are used at
the object level,
and can only grant access
to individual objects.
In general, we recommend using
Cloud IAM to authorize access
to GCS because it is integrated
with so many security
and privacy features,
like domain restricted
sharing and Cloud [? analog. ?]
Since objects can
have unique ACLs,
it gets harder to tell who
has access to your data
the longer your bucket
has been in production.
Imagine having to iterate across
millions or billions of objects
in order to check to see
if a specific user is
granted or denied
access to any objects.
You can see that
this can quickly
become a maintenance burden.
And our recommendation
for managing lots
of object ACLs at scale is
to not manage them at all.
By enabling uniform
bucket-level access,
you are disabling object
ACLs and using the bucket
policy for all access control.
Every object is
treated the same,
and every object
benefits from all
of IAM's feature integrations.
An added benefit to
using this feature
is that GCS can now share
access decisions for objects
within the same bucket.
Caching is improved, which
is great for [INAUDIBLE] use
cases.
And we understand that
some of our customers
continue to use GCS ACLs
for different reasons,
whether it's because of their
multi cloud architecture
or because ACLs allow
you to share an object
with an individual user.
In general it is
not a best practice
to put in end users
on your object ACLs,
so I'd like to recommend
some alternatives.
First, signed URLs.
Signed URLs allow you to
delegate time limited access
to GCS resources.
Your code generates a URL which
contains authentication info
in the query string that's tied
to a specific identity, usually
a service account.
And that URL is sent to
an end user for download.
Second, if you notice that
certain groups of objects
happen to share the same access
pattern within your bucket,
like they have the
same object ACL set,
then this might
be a sign that you
should be using separate
buckets, one for each use case.
And lastly, if
your app makes use
of shared prefixes
in object naming,
then you could also use IAM
conditions to [? show ?] access
based on those prefixes.
And finally, I'd like to
explain some best practices
when using HMAC keys on GCS.
First off, we recommend
service account HMAC
over user account HMAC.
Service accounts,
in general, they
offer more reliability
because they
are tied to the lifetime
of the cloud project,
whereas user accounts are not.
The user account can
easily be deleted
outside the context of GCP.
For example, when a collaborator
leaves the organization
or when an employee
leaves the company.
If this happens, deactivating
that user account would also
deactivate their
HMAC keys and this
would result in access denied
errors for any code that
was relying on those keys.
So we definitely recommend
using service account HMAC
keys in a production service.
Other things we recommend, we
recommend rotating your keys
and only granting
your service accounts
just enough permissions
to accomplish whatever
task they're trying to do.
And lastly, if you're
using V2 signatures,
we recommend setting
reasonable expiration times,
as well as eventually
migrating to V4.
V4 enforces a max
time limit of one
week, whereas V2 has no
limit which can be risky.
All right, time for a demo.
All right, let's begin the demo
by enabling the org policies
that I mentioned in the best
practices section before.
To do this, we'll go to
the org policy editor,
and we will configure
domain restricted sharing
and uniform bucket level access.
So let's start
with the first one.
And for domain
restricted sharing,
you're going to
need your domain ID,
and if you don't
know that off the top
of your head, no worries.
You can use G Cloud to
list the organizations
that you have access to.
You can see here, I have a test
org and this value on the right
is going to be my domain ID.
So when I throw it here-- that
here into the policy value,
select save.
Great.
Now only members of this domain
ID are allowed on IAM policies
anywhere in my project.
Go back to this org
policy view, select
enforce, and we will customize
and set the enforcement on,
as well.
So now that I have
configured This org policy,
for uniform bucket level
access, any new bucket
will have to use
that feature which
will greatly simplify access
control across objects
in buckets.
From here, let's go
to a storage browser
and see these org
policies in action.
So we create bucket.
Let's call this
bucket gcs-next-onair.
We'll use the defaults for data
location and storage class.
And we can see here
that the org policy
I enabled earlier enforces
uniform for access control.
I'm going to create
the bucket now.
And let's make sure domain
restricted sharing is also
in effect, as well.
So to do that, we'll
go to permissions
and we'll try to add something
that's outside the domain.
If I were to add all users,
which would grant access
to everyone making the
bucket publicly exposed
on the internet, that would
violate the domain restricted
sharing org policy, and so
I am expecting this to fail.
And we see that the
policy update failed
and it's because the org
policy was put in place.
So that's good.
If we can't add all users
as a member, who can we add?
Well, most of the time when
you run a production service,
you want to use
service accounts.
So prior to this demo, I
had created an object viewer
service account.
It doesn't actually have
object viewer permissions,
but I just named it
object viewer, just
for the sake of simplicity.
So if I go back
to storage browser
and I update the
permissions here,
I should be able to add that
service account to my bucket.
And when I give it the same
permission that I tried before,
storage object viewer which
has read access to objects,
and I'm going to select save.
And because this is configured
at the bucket level,
my service account is
going to have access
to all objects
within this bucket.
As you can see, I haven't
added any objects yet,
so I'm going to go
ahead and do that now.
Here I have some folders that
have some text files in them.
Let me drag and drop
them here onto the UI.
All three folders have
different prefixes but they
all have the same
text files in them--
apples, bananas and cherries.
So how do we confirm that our
service account actually has
access to all these objects?
Well, easy way to do it is
to use service account HMAC.
You go to settings,
interoperability, create key
for your service account.
I already have a key set up
here but I don't remember
the secret for it,
so I am just going
to go ahead and make a new key.
Got over to
terminal, you can see
that I have [? this get ?]
object metadata
with HMAC key script.
This script reads from
environment variables
that I have to
export, so I'm going
to go ahead and do that now.
Exported the access key, and
we'll do the secret next.
Great.
So now if I run the
script and I try
to access my bucket
objects, I should
see that access is granted.
And you can see that we
have successfully touched
the metadata for this object.
Let me try some of
the other files.
Looks like access
has been granted.
Great.
So if you go back
to the browser,
I mentioned earlier
that I wanted
to show you an example
of IAM conditions.
So with IAM conditions you
could set an object prefix,
which would limit the access to
objects with a certain prefix
in the name.
So instead of granting access
to every object in the bucket,
let's say I only wanted to
grant access to those with 2020
in the name.
So to do that, go back to
the bucket permissions page,
I don't need to add the member
because the service account is
already on the bucket policy,
all I have to do is edit it.
So from here, I can
add a condition.
Let me call it 2020 prefix.
And for condition type,
we'll do resource name.
Starts with, and we have to
specify a resource name format.
So, the format's different
for each GCP service,
so this table right
here is really nice.
And you can see that
Cloud Storage Objects
follows this format, so
I'm going to grab that,
copy it in here.
For object name, it's
not an object name,
it's going to be a prefix.
I'm going to do 2020
slash, and for bucket name
I'm going to put gcs-next-onair,
in the bucket, click save.
Now that I have this
setup, I'm going
to check to make sure that
I have access only to 2020
and not the other two.
2018 should fail
now, access denied.
2019 should also
fail, I'm going to try
some other files, also denied.
But if we make it 2020,
access should be granted.
Great.
And that's how you set up a
object prefix IAM condition.
And with that, that
concludes the demo.
Thank you very much.
SUBHASISH CHAKRABORTY:
Thank you, Chester.
To conclude, as you have
seen in this session,
GCS offers [? plan ?]
scale, object or blob
storage with a simple
and unified API,
and online latency
characteristics.
And it addresses a whole
wide range of use cases
we see customers use this for.
Security is built into GCS
by design and default, not as
an afterthought.
And as you saw from
the various GA features
that Chester just
talked about, we
are continuing to innovate
and invest very heavily
in the security capabilities
to address your requirements
and concerns.
With GCS you can confidently
store your data at scale
and trust us to keep your
data secure and safe.
With that, I would
recommend if you haven't yet
tried some of these GA features,
or if you haven't tried some
of these secretive best
practices that we discovered,
give it a shot and let us know.
Thank you.